good-morning reject nation this is Greg
outlet yeah G Ahnold here we are going
towards the final trailer for fantastic
beasts the cons of Grindelwald I'm very
excited for this film before we go into
this guys wanted to mention we are on
the Stardust app people they are not
sponsoring this video even though they
should but on the Stardust app you can
do 30-second reactions for films
television shows and trailers often
things that we do not talk about here on
YouTube we will talk about over there
movies ever catching up on sometimes we
do little like micro sketches instead of
doing a review and you know some people
might complain it they're not reviews
but that's about it either way
it's a really fun time by the way check
out john bailey on there i would love it
if you guys can go follow us there's a
link in the description box pin comment
as well the community's really grown a
lot over there a lot of other youtubers
are using as well so go follow us first
peeps and a-one and to a safe house in
Paris
why do I need a safe house a battery
strip things at some point but terribly
wrong it's good to have a place to go
you know
[Music]
especially fast
my dreams we who live the moment is come
Oh daddy take whoa the word snake yeah
makini
[Music]
window wall wants to see that piece
destroy music why can't you
[Music]
it has to be you
emotions they can see I do not seek
power you should be honest is the thing
oh you got the beasts yeah that's right
when you have to pick a side I don't do
what are you doing
[Music]
we do something huge
you never met a monster you couldn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know I I don't know a lot about
Harry Potter but I'm pretty sure the
young Grindelwald is the same actor who
played him and the deathly hallows
really yeah I guess I do that actors
like I think that's the same dude
actually I've kind of the same thought
you getting partway through this and
being like oh yeah this is a fantastic
beast story and not like the Harry
Potter yeah not just like a further
extension of all the backstory of the
Harry Potter world yeah it's like I
wonder if the beasts are gonna figure it
just seems like such an afterthought at
this point it seems like mostly Grindle
and like Grindelwald is a pretty
significant character in the lore of
Harry Potter I mean everybody you know I
was freaking out about are they gonna
allude to the potential romance between
him and Dumbledore and whatnot you know
I gotta say Johnny Depp you know like
all personal thoughts aside what
everyone has to say about man I know
that it can be a distracting experience
for some especially I hope he does a
good one and it looks like you're doing
a good job yeah it's like he's very well
suited to this character and especially
where he is right now I feel like this
is perhaps the most palatable thing he
could be doing because you know he's in
the best place in the public eye so you
know what they say you know play a
villain or whatever
oh but yeah their name even I recognize
I didn't know she was she human before I
mean is that in the Harry Potter books
this is where I gotta go back in and
retest Maya I don't a hundred thousand
percent
remember examine the biggest part is
she's an Asian woman I know
look at that progressive diversity yeah
she's the chick the doctor doctor lady
and age of Ultron
we all remember that characters in the
human yeah I think she's probably best
known for Marco Polo which is a show
I've watched all of yeah definitely I
mean that's cool yeah our diversity
train going that's a fantastic beast if
I ever saw one now if we can only have
Jude Law actually doing some gay stuff
everyone will be happy I know even
Freddie Mercury I feel like both these
movies at campaigns is where's the game
these things in especially Harry I feel
like oddly if that's gonna be an issue I
do feel like they ought to do something
with this movie just because JK Rowling
bothered to come out and be like hey
this isn't super obvious in the books
but Dumbledore is gay and newts brother
is he a bad guy that's the impression I
get looks like he's working with Grendel
I mean he says let's get him but I don't
know there's something about him that
seems villainous mistake yeah I guess
that would be my guess and certainly for
a Harry Potter story that seems like the
kind of challenge they might throw a
significant characters way but also he's
in this lineup here so maybe he's in
some kind of double agent capacity or
maybe it's one of those things worse
like you've spent time with Grindelwald
come help us out I feel sorry for a nude
he's in over a lot of people find Eddie
Redmayne very attractive but it's very
obvious he's playing them you know the
better-looking more charming older
brother here yeah and at one point I
guess it looked like they were in some
kind of World War one scenario or
something they were like planes flying
over there in the middle of a
battlefield this is kind of fascinating
to me because I thought the first one
was pretty good but it had some stuff to
build on so I'm hoping that this can at
least reach the heights because it seems
like what they really want to do is take
this and turn it into something that can
still convey a you know relatable and
very timely message I'm sure you know it
seems like they're going up against a
figure who's not hard to kind of
parallel into today's times what the
impression I'm getting though is trying
to figure out where this prequel
evolution is going because the first one
wasn't really all that linked this one
had a lot more linked with having
Dumbledore there the end of the hint of
Nagini I'm
imagining that when this might segue
with like the third or fourth a guy like
eight of these yeah I imagine it might
segue to like having more of a Voldemort
origin as well I could definitely see
that happening I mean III definitely
wouldn't put it past anybody to want to
take a bunch of prequels and then find a
way to connect them directly back in
there and the thing is just that Harry
Potter is so prolific and fantastic
beasts and where to find them like is a
real book but it literally is just an
encyclopedia of different creatures so
and Groot is crossing over here they
have one thirty one and two fantastic
beasts and where to find it yeah I guess
that's a big thing as I just I'm curious
as to where the title stuff is gonna
figure in because this movie this
trailer makes it look like that could
very much be an afterthought unless you
know Newt is gonna use them like as his
this is my multi-tool like I got all
these creatures and they're gonna help
me in every situation fighting this evil
Dark Wizard but they're probably
supporting characters for a push to the
side in this movie yeah which doesn't
altogether not make sense but yeah still
fascinating yeah but other than this
stuff I'm just excited to get back to
the Harry Potter world I mean that's
it's arguably my favorite part of the
first movies yeah anyway before we wrap
this up wanted to give a patron the day
shout out to a man named Taylor Ben Lee
Taylor Bentley's a young handsome man
that I don't talk with often enough he
hasn't replied back to me lately and I
think I know why the guy got hitched
people not married he just landed
himself a hot girlfriend that he claimed
is way out of his league he has no idea
how he got her honestly man I've seen
your photos you know really handsome guy
you're very charming kind guy it totally
makes sense to me tell you so how you
got a hot girl but if I were to give you
a piece of advice man you got to get one
of these luggages that Newt has because
women can be like beasts and they're you
try to get away all the time they're
fantastic creatures but sometimes you
got to keep them stored away that way
you can keep them as your property yeah
and if you've got a new case I mean
think about it they won't even want to
leave because they can just live in your
suitcase mansion they got everything
they need who cares
gosh the shoutout is no sarcasm at all
ever
to all the women out there and the men
who have heard this shoutout
it is not sarcasm it is me embodying
John everyone loves you you can't make
jokes anymore people America's
Sweetheart no dude congratulations on
the girlfriend be really kind to her
treat her with the utmost respect
because if she's way out of your league
you don't want to mess that up with
being insecure my friend and don't do a
cameo in a weird movie with her that's
gonna get released and shoved onto DVD
like you know I'm absolutely dude
absolutely yeah so just be as kind of
respectful tour as you can and you know
make sure to get her something good for
Christmas and don't let her dress too
[ __ ] for Halloween boys anyway guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell check this
out on patreon TV show reactions Q&A is
also make sure to follow us on the start
us app it's free link in the description
box people